well in art certainly contemporary arts
job is to is to wreck whatever came
before it and from the very beginning
after the after the old masters from
Nana on each generation wrecked Matt
that's something that's pretty and
beautiful is probably the worst thing
you could say today in contemporary art
about something unless it's so pretty
it's nauseating so um and people that
most people have great contempt about
contemporary art and I find that
hilarious because i did a pieces that
contemporary art hate you and it does
hate them because you can't see it you
don't know the magic trick you haven't
learned the vocabulary you haven't
learned the special way of seeing it's
something that changes it and and that
is like joining a biker gang that is but
you do have to be able to appreciate all
kinds of taste and the contemporary art
that I like dust is the kind that
initially angers you and so now this is
rip attend that's so great I saw a
painting last night that was that I
really want to buy but yeah it's a
dilemma it's by Karen Sandra artists I'd
like and collect but this painting she
just took a blank canvas and left it
outside until I got mold and everything
and it's really ugly but I thought she
had struggle she didn't do one thing but
the problem was buying it is that the
mold will spread in your house and it's
toxic so this to me is the best art
piece I've seen all year I'm still
trying to figure out how I could own it
without poisoning myself
I always wanted to make people angry and
make him laugh though to be surprised I
mean my early movies were made for a
hippie audience us who went to midnight
movies but I was a local I guess like I
have been had long hair I thought the
revolution was coming but I was a hippie
you know I answer I made fun of hippies
by making violent movies like multiple
maniacs and thankful mingos but the
hippies always liked it the same way
today in my book role models I have
chapters that are fairly rude you know
about outsider pornographers and men
that go down and out houses and people
on him and but no one seems to
eject it was on the bestseller list in
the Midwest I think isn't that amazing
that's in libraries and and um you know
I wrote a very impatient piece about
trying to free one of the man's and
women which not anybody got that
controversy about that the only thing
I've said on the books were that causes
people to go crazy was in San Francisco
I said I thought they had good public
transportation and there were all these
blogs that has John Waters lost his mind
so I thought that was the only
controversial thing I said so things are
it's odd people i guess if they buy my
book they expect to be a little bit
surprised that's what they're paying the
money for they'd be disappointed if they
weren't
I I think there's not an ironic sentence
and role models I don't write about
anybody that was so bad they're good and
even in my movies the and Baltimore and
all that kind of thing I'm looking up to
those people I'm asking you to come into
their world and marvel I'm never asking
you like reality television to look down
on them and make fun of them feel
superior I think it's a big big
difference I don't think my even my my
most extreme films were ever
mean-spirited really i mean pink
flamingos divine was minding her own
business writing her memoirs in the
woods when she was challenged by a
jealous pervert I think I think my
movies are politically correct in a
weird way and moral
well the morality in my movies has mind
your own business you don't know what
caused people to act the way they do and
and and so until you know all that and
you've heard all the evidence it's none
of your business I couldn't believe
everybody went crazy about Tiger Woods
well he didn't run for Pope I don't care
who he slept with what he shouldn't care
why sleep with they all said he was
great too that's the thing I what's he
upset about every person said he was the
best ever